how to sell your products and services  to more people than you could ever  believe if you want to expand your  marketing it's not necessarily reaching  new avatars but actually having  different people in the advertisements  for your products and services for  example i look like this and push the  audience that follows me looks like this  most times people subconsciously will  recognize or identify with people who  look like them so if i were selling  weight loss it's ingrained in how people  think i want to have a bigger brand and  reach more people even though eating  less and working out more is going to  help any of these avatars what i need to  do is have spokespeople who represent  the different demographics and  psychographics that encompass the entire  audience and so in doing that i can  actually expand my marketplace expand  the amount of people that i can reach  without actually changing my product or  services